So I don't work on refugees
specifically i work on migration writ large
My contribution here tonight
is maybe to frame this question
around what we understand the refugee
crisis to be. And how we define or
distinguish rather refugees from
migrants. So the concept of a refugee is
actually a legal concept that emerged in
the immediate post-war years.
The convention was ratified in 1951
It is a distinction that grew out of the
failure of European countries primarily
to deal with the World War II refugees
the massive movement of people who had
been displaced by this cataclysmic event.
This is the distinction that we still use.
And we haven't deployed it or
thought through it as deliberately as
we've been thinking about it over the
past five years because the major
refugee crisis or the major forced
displacements of people have been in
areas that have received far less
coverage in the US and in Europe--so
primarily sub-Saharan Africa. and with
internal displacement in sub-Saharan Africa
and Latin America--Columbia primarily.
Columbia has a huge internally
displaced persons problem. In fact it was
interesting in your map that the causes
for displacement we're all natural
disasters but in fact in Colombia
the major cause of displacement is
actually violence and civil war.
So my understanding is that it might
be helpful to present a little bit of
the "long now"
Yes would that be helpful? That's always welcome.
Right, so this notion (refugee status) is a notion
that emerged right after
after World  War II. And for the US,
the North Atlantic region, and Europe
migration has been for the most part this
steady regulated flow of people.There have been labor movement
accords. So Europe imported
guest workers from North Africa, from
Turkey the US signed the Bracero program
with Mexico. So these
regulated flows that had informal
undocumented components, but no big spikes.
The big spike is what has drawn our
attention--the big spike to Europe--has
drawn our attention to the refugee
crisis today. Lebanon and Turkey and
Jordan have experienced these flows in
big numbers really since the beginning
of the Civil War. The US in
particular has in its history--and I know
there's an American historian in our
audience here, so I may stand corrected--
but in its history the US has
experienced these big spikes and has
not had the same kind of anxiety around
these big spikes in the past. One
example that for me is very poignant is
the Irish potato famine. So Ireland
between 01847, which was
the first year of the famine, and 01851
lost 1.5 million people. It was a population in the
last census before the famine
listed the population of Ireland at 8 million.
So it's an equivalent number to the
kind of displacement proportionally that
you see from Syria today. Most of,
a huge number, of Irish ended up in New York, in Boston,
in Philadelphia, and in Montreal, Toronto...
They traveled across the Atlantic
in slave ships that had been
repurposed for the movement of Irish
immigrants. And Manhattan which in 01847
had a population of 300,000 received
200,000 Irish people in two years.
Its population grew by 1/4.
So did set the population of
Boston, Philadelphia... one more city that
I'm forgetting. Baltimore, maybe?
No, Chicago didn't get a lot of Irish.
They got a lot of Germans who moved
to the Midwest. But these
populations were not tagged as refugees.
They were just seen as migrants. And the
cities that received them absorbed them.
We didn't tag them differently.
The tagging of refugees as
distinct from migrants is a
new phenomenon. As is the sense that cities
in Europe and North America cannot
absorb them. We have in the past and it
wasn't as traumatic as one might think.
It has shaped our understanding of things like
infrastructure and poverty. But basically
we have in the past had this
capacity. And it's this new tagging that
has transformed our vision of what we
can absorb and what we can't absorb.